it's very very difficult for people
people are facing higher fuel bills
higher food bills and what i would do
immediately is reverse the national
insurance increase keeping more money in
people's pockets also have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy to
cut fuel bills but also work to increase
energy supply because that's what the
issue is we've got a shortage of supply
of energy we need to get on with that we
need to get more gas out to north sea we
need to look at fracking
in parts of the country that support
that and we need to get on with bringing
those supplies on stream yeah everyone
would agree there is a supply problem
but that takes time and the problem with
tax cuts is they're only good for tax
payers so that wouldn't help the
pensioners you know 45 of who are on a
state pension next january that's going
to be almost half half their pension
will go on energy bills and it won't
help the millions who don't even pay any
tax well keeping taxes low is vitally
important for growing our economy and
avoiding a recession and that is my
priority because with a growing economy
there's more money coming into the
government's coffers we're able to do
more to
invest in our infrastructure invest in
our public services but also put more
money into people's pockets right across
the country and of course you know
pensioners are through their pensions
investing
in science parks like this and that's
what i want to do i want to unlock those
opportunities unlock the growth
increase energy supplies
and help people firstly through reducing
their taxes because what's wrong is
taking money from people in taxes and
then giving it back to them in benefits
that's and brown style economics and i
don't support that so you are ruling out
cash payments in whatever form to people
then and you will only help people
through tax cuts that's not what i said
okay what i said is my priority is
making sure we're not taking money off
people and then giving it back to them
later on i believe in people keeping
their own money and i believe in a low
tax economy that's the way we're going
to drive growth i'm not going to
announce the contents of a budget in the
future at this stage in august but i
could assure people i would do all i can
to make sure that energy is affordable
and that we get through this winter yeah
a lot of people are saying that we need
to make announcements now because the
price gap is going up in a couple of
weeks many people are really anxious uh
you know it's exacerbating that anxiety
for so many people and that you know
there's some people who said why you
can't get together with richie soon app
or it's johnson and put aside your
differences maybe on the costume come to
a consensus so you can assure that
that i'm sure there's millions of people
whoever becomes prime minister well
obviously not bryce johnson but at the
viewing rishi soon after that will at
least they know that there will be help
in place once we get to september the
fifth or sixth well i can assure people
that if elected as prime minister i will
do all i can to deal with this issue and
i will take action on day one
first of all with the temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy
which will save people money on their
fuel bills but also reversing the
national insurance increase but we have
a proper constitution in this country we
have a prime minister we have a
chancellor they make the decisions at
the moment my job is foreign secretary
it's also vitally important we continue
to stand up to putin
because that's a lot of the cause of
this problem is the way that russia is
trying to use european energy as
leverage in their appalling war in
ukraine so it's important i continue as
in my job as foreign secretary to stand
up to putin and of course
the prime minister and chancellor
continue to work to solve this issue